[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم ابراهيم
انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى
ال محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما
بعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سوره الانعام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه
[Silence]
‏other
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
قل تعالوا اتلوا ما حرم ربكم عليكم الا
تشركوا به شيئا
speaking صلى الله عليه وسلم
upite
upon you that which your lord has made
prohibited upon you all
first that you not associate
الا تشركوا به شيئا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
in our belief is unique he is one we do
not describe others with his
descriptions we do
الله
any
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏any
love
anyو
احسان
and
ولا تقتلوا اولادكم من املاق نحن نرزقكم
واياهم
ولا تقربوا الفواحش ما ظهر منها وما بطن
[Silence]
‏private ولا تقتل النفس التي حرم الله
الا بالحق
الله
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تعقلون
ولا تقرب مال اليتيم الا بالتي هي احسن
يبلغ اشده
‏in
الله
do not come close to
this is a more stringent prohibition
than merely saying do not do such and
such he saying don't even come near
‏unalth
oranf
me and
with fairness and justice the
measurements and the weights
‏take
more
if you are mer give your measure give
him
and if you are
do not take from the merant more than
you have
so he say andulf the meas andight
لا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها
واذا قلتم فاعدلوا
و كان ذا قرب
وبفوا
[Silence]
‏are
in
name
are all things الله comm you and you in
order you
وان هذا صراطي مستقيما فاتبعوه
ولا تتبعوا السبل فتفرق بكم عن سبيله
‏any other
take you
will take
all things الله comm you and
قال ابن مسعود من اراد ان ينظر الى وصيه
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم التي عليها خاتمه
فليقرا قوله تعالى قل تعالوا اتل ما حرم
ربكم
عليكم الا تشركوا به شيئا الى قوله وان
هذا صراطي مستقيما الايه ابن مسعود عبد
الله بن مسعود رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه
الحبشه
مدين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عبد الله بن مسعود
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
number 1512
سوره الانعام
ابن مسعود
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
why need
[Silence]
‏and
would
قال وعن معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه قال كنت
رديف النبي صلى صلى الله عليه وسلم على
حمار
رديف يعني راكب ورا على حمار فقال لي يا
معاذ اتدري ما حق الله على العباد وما حق
العباد على الله قلت الله ورسوله اعلم
قال حق الله على العباد ان يعبدوه ولا
يشركوا به شيئا وحق العباد على الله الا
يعذب من لا يشرك به شيئا قلت يا رسول الله
افلا ابشر الناس قال لا تبشرهم فيتكلوا
لا تبشرهم فيتكلوا يعني لا
تحكي لعامه الناس هذا الكلام لان اكثر
الناس يتكلوا يعني يكسلوا عن العمل
يعتمدوا على هذا شيء يقول ما الحمد لله
انا مسلم وانا اقول لا اله الا الله ولا
اشرك به شيئا اذا مضمون لي الجنه فيتكل
على هذا ويترك العمل
قال اخرجاه في الصحيحين
بخاري مسلم
معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه معاذ بن جبل
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
very
معاذ بن جبل
ان جامع الترمذي صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد
واعلم امتي بالحلال والحرام معاذ بن
صلى الله عليه وسلم
حلال حرام معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه
معاذ بن جبل
كون
مدينه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مدين
سير
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بن جبل
صلى الله عليه
ك معاذ بن جبل
[Silence]
would
you sit with as
[Silence]
‏to
andere
some of them very insincere
intention very bad intention and so they
would try
‏was
trying to spin things
and soit
theران
and so proparنا
هذا الحديث في جامع الترمذي
معاذ بن جبل
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
[Silence]
‏place
this ver et and from those
other companions would come
so
when to newes
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلمرصلا
خطبه رضي الله صلى الله عليه وسلم معاذ بن
جبل
standing
with prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابوذر
يمن
معاذ بن جبل ابوذر يمن
[Silence]
معاذ جبل
معاذ بن جبل
حلال حرام معاذ بن جبل
was
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
معاذ ابو ذر
يوصيهما
فيقول بشرا ولا تنفرا ويسرا ولا تعسرا
واتفقا ولا تختلفا
انك تقدم على قوم اهلك كتاب فليكن اول ما
تدعوهم اليه عباده الله
وفي روايه الى ان يوحدوا الله
and
the
‏by himself
and said
perhaps
likely when you come back not find
because wasending
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم passed away
back in
الخطاب
اليمامه
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
عمر
الشام عبد الله بن عمر was
there and there until
the
pass through ‏and he
passed away in the pl the what is known
as theonic pl it's the black pl he
passed away in during that wave of the
black that passed through very famous
thing that happen in the time of and you
would think man this guy must be very
old to have had all of these
accomplishments he
رضي الله عنه
ان شاء الله
next نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه
وجوده ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يجعلنا ممن
يعرفونه ويعبدونه حق العباده نساله سبحانه
وتعالى
ا ان يعيذنا من ان نشرك به شيئا ونحن نعلم
ونساله ان يغفر لنا ما لم نكن نعلم والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
هذا مقدمنا ما شاء
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
[Silence]
حي على
حي على صلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
حي على الفلاح ا
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
[Silence]
مح
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فان الله تعالى يقول في كتابه الكريم
ولو ان قرانا
سيرت
به الجبال او قطعت به الارض او كلم به
الموتى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
very
عل وسلم
those who refuse theران
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
‏ar
presented
to the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
is said
we would and prom you if you
perform this mirle that we descri to you
now we will believe in you
we
‏you to ask your lord your god to
to us a book from him that when it
isited
the mountains crumble
and the earth splits apart
and the dead speak to us.
‏Now these are descriptions of the day
of judgement
and this is also one of their one of
their ar
if
is going to happ make it happ now they
would say to the propet
and so they said we want that when weite
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولو ان قرانا
سيرت به الجبال
او قطعت به الارض او كلم به الموتى
اي لكان هذا القران
لكن الله تعالى لم يجعل ذلك في شيء من
كتبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الرعد
in which
‏the mountains move from their place
and the spitsart and the dead speak
if Allah to place that kind of power in
any b in any books that he sent down to
prop anders
ages
would thisران
that was by صلى الله عليه
‏ofitرes
[Silence]
and
tell
thisران
this
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and
that isy
of moving
from their place just shy of splitting
the earth apart just shy of causing the
dead to rise
اللهران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما من الانبياء من نبي الا واعطي من
الايات ما مثله امن عليه البشر
وانما الذي اوتيته وحيا اوحاه الله الي
فارجو ان اكون اكثرهم تابعا يوم القيامه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
that was given miracles that could
perform miracles so compelling that
people would
that
‏upon these compelling miracles he said
and the greatest mirle that i have been
given isation
theران
the words of almighty الله himself
as he spoke them toil
and asbril descended uponall
عليه وسلم
رضي الله
‏and hopefulers
among the prop anders
ofctionle
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ادم عليه السلامر
[Silence]
‏by
الله سبحانه وتالى
our greatest achievement
as human being there is no greater
blessing and no greater achievement for
any human
الله
understand الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الرحمن
علم القران خلق الانسان علمه البيان
الله
رqu
the communication
theil
to nothend
comp thoughts
سبحانه وتعالى madeر
ر
[Silence]
noch
noy
ever
ஷine
رable
is at ouringer
in our time most of us have access to
the qu instantaneously anywh we are it
has never been more ubiquitous
in physical presence
‏are
underarn
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم tells us in
certain termsكم
تعلم القران وعلمه
‏He said the best of you
are those who learn the Quran
and teach it. The best of you. There is
no one
better than the one who learns the b of
Allah
and subsequently teaches others the B
of.
‏notitingar
toite
you not understand this is not and end
all of achievement
true achievement is that a person learn
the qu
learn meaning ody those meanings
implement those meanings and
انس بن مالك رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان لله تعالى اهلين من الناس
قالوا يا رسول الله من هم؟ قال اهل القران
هم اهل الله وخاصته
صلى
عليه وسلم
الله
[Silence]
‏am
سبحانه وتالى are peopleر
are thosearnite
no the people ofران are those
quر
thosearn from the quر those impement the
قران
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله تعليقا على هذه
الروايه
اهل القران هم اهل الله وخاصته
قال اهل القران
هم الذين يقراونه
ويفهمون معانيه
ويعملون به وان لم يحفظوه
ومن حفظ القران
وتلاه
واقام حروفه
اقامه السهم ولم يفهم معناه ولم يعمل بما
فيه ليس من اهل القران
رحمه الله تعالى
‏thosearnan
and those
it andulf commandments
from prohibitions most perfectly even if
they do not mor the entirety of the qu
he said and those whoor the in entiry
and even
‏and notement
teaching they are not of the people of
the quر even if they comm to
the people are those
who contemplate meaning thosearn from it
صلى الله عليه وسلم
والقران
حجه لك او عليك ويقول صلى الله عليه وسلم
القران شافع مشفع وماحل مصدق
من جعله بين يديه قاده الى الجنه ومن جعله
وراء ظهره ساقه
الى النار
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
الله
undg
الله عليه وسلمرell
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم القران حجه لك اوك
مالك صحيح مسلمان
ران
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
‏ar
youg
if you put you it guid you parad it lead
you parad and your back to it it willush
you into thees ofellر
the b of
greatest
‏by usion of these
and inv all things this is
the glitter
theusion of
all things will be
there is no skysraper
‏we
to establish
jce andous on
not toable
not wealthy if those things come
sure but that's not what we were created
‏not
الله
inv all this
‏byproduct of our this is a byproduct of
our existence this is not the purpose
for our existence
we ex in order to impement andold
الا الله upon the earth الله سبحانه
وتالى said اني جاعل في الارض خليفه
‏upon
a to
a success to one anotheran
each generation takes the place of the
generation before it and builds upon
that generation achievement and success
to the creator
upon
‏that we estish
and law upon this is why we created and
when we become distracted when we start
to take this world as primary and here
as secondary and derivative
we will ne achieve greatness in this
life nor the hereafter we will both
that's not why we were created
الله
[Silence]
يقول
الشيخ ابو العباس رحمه الله تعالى وكما ان
العين لا ترى الا مع وجود نور قدامه
فكذلك العقل لا يرى حتى تطلع عليه شمس
الرساله
حساب رحمه الله تعالى
without
it to be able to
the human in will not be able to
properly until the light of the quر and
rises upon it
‏if
and and
gr
and gu by theران
wasent
قول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه
انه هو الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم اللهم اننا
عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو ايمائك نواصينا في
يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك
بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك او انزلته في
كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او استاثرت
به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل القران ربيع
قلوبنا
نور صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
اللهم علمنا منه ما جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نسالك
فعل الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا
اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين اللهم استعملنا قبل موتنا اللهم
استعملنا قبل موتنا اللهم استعملنا ولا
تستبدلنا يا رب العالمين اللهم اننا نرفع
اليك اكفنا نتبتل اليك يا ربنا ان تنصر
اخواننا المجاهدين في غزه وفلسطين
وفي كل مكان حيث حلوا يا رب العالمين.
اللهم انصرهم على من عاداهم واجعل ثارهم
على من ظلمهم واجعلهم على عدوهم قاهرين
ظاهرين
منصورين اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم فانهم لا
يعجزونك اللهم صدع بنيانهم وزلزل اركانهم
اللهم اقتل اجنادهم اللهم اجعلهم في ذل وص
صغار وهوان يا رب العالمين وردهم خائبين
مكبوتين
مقموحين يا رب العالمين اللهم اجعل قتلاهم
في النيران واجعل قتلانا في الجنان اللهم
اننا نعوذ بك من الزنا والربا والغلى
والزلازل والفتن ما ظهر منها وما بطن
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك
و واقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول بيننا وبين
معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن
اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ما احييتنا
واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من
ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عادانا اللهم اننا
نسالك عيش السعداء ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه
الانبياء والنصر على الاعداء يا سميع
الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء اللهم امين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
[Arabic recitation]
‏until the is full align your shoulders
and feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two nebors on side of you
straightening the is part of that
command us with our
استووا ولا تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
الله اكبر سبحان الله
اسمك جدك ونا
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان شيطان الرجيم بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
واخرج خرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان ما لها
يومئذ
تحدث اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى لها
يومئذ
يسطر الناس اشتاتا ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا را
يره
ومن يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا
يره
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
سبحان الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
القارع
ما القارع
وما
ادراكما
القارع
يوم يكون الناس كالفراش
المبثوث
وتكون تكون الجبال كالعهن المنفوش
فاما من ثقلت موازينه
فهو في عيشه راضيه
واما من خفت موازينه
فامه
هاويه
وما
ادراك ما هي
نار
حاميه
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرلامسلام
علينا وعلى الصالحين اشهد ان لا اله الا
اللهم صل
الله
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تباركت ربنا
মাই ব্রাদার সিস্টার আসসালামু আলাইকুম
থি
অপশন প্লিজ ইনশআল্লাহফস্ট
ফজ ইনশ্লা
মনিং
মনিং ফজ 545 5
7:30 পিএম
ইনশল্লাহ
শেখ আলি অিসার
5 পম
সন্
5 পথ
সন্ড ইশল্লাহ pleasன்
‏in
after
q so after
satday q and you have any question the
time
sister and classes are 11 am to 1 পm on
satড
of you know there b for the here the
‏Ball pr which is from 4 to 6 wesday and
frid
and there a club are two s there s a and
b for by groups and that is 130 and 230
respectiv
is going to be after is between mag and
is so between magbab and is there is a
fly out and between magh and is today is
going to be a different groups for the
searate for
‏and
pleas make you all
there is also enrement for the comp
that's be the year
enment so pleas to
about enment and if you can get en
‏I want to with you since we have
for the raising the
state prit
our academy be talking about it next
and our go isy hey last year we were
able to00
from this to benit our academy and this
year this number is going be at least00
and i see brother
তাকবরc
তাকবরলাকুমহমাতুল্লাহ